AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
WILL COME TO ORDER A GOOD
AFTERNOON THE RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF. THE PUBLIC AND
ARE SOON PLEASE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH MID MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORST
WISH TO TESTIFY. TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANTS
FREE NUMBER IN ACTS CO POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE NOW.
TODAY'S PRODUIT PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR A
REPEAT THAT. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX SIX
FIVE FIVE SEVEN FIVE A REPEAT.
SIX SIX FIVE. SEVEN FIVE SEVEN.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATE WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID THE ACOUSTIC
FOOD FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE.
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. OR
LISTENING TO HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING. TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR. FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I'LL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE USE. AND THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
AC ELEVEN AZ EIGHT FOUR IS
JOINTLY AUTHORED BY SIMPLY
MEMBERS MULLIN AND LOW- IN A
RELEASE TO ELECTIONS IN IN
VOTING AGE AN ACA ELEVEN WILL
BE PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MALL AND ITS THE- HOME
PROTECTION FOR SENIORS SEVERELY
DISABLED. FAMILIES OF VICTIMS
OF WILD FIRE OR NATURAL
DISASTERS. ACT OF BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM MR MULLIN AYE I
NOTICED PRESIDENT CHOIR BUT
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO
MISTER SECRETARY COULD I ASK
YOU TO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
NUMBER THEIR NUMBER HERE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA HERE LEYVA
HERE STERN. WE HAVE COR ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU WERE
MISSING A SENATORS STERN AND
HERTZBERG BUT WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT SO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND LOW IF YOU'RE
PREPARED WILL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH THE PRESENTATION ON
A SEE A- FOR. SEVEN THE REMOTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PRESENTING A CA FOR
WITH MY JOINT AUTHORS MR LOW.
VOTER TURNOUT IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS IS CONSISTENTLY LOWER
THAT OBSERVE TURNOUT LEVELS FOR
GENERAL ELECTIONS ACCORDING TO
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF ELIGIBLE
VOTERS PARTICIPATED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GENERAL
ELECTION. FOR ONLY 28%
PARTICIPATED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PRIMARY. RESEARCH ALSO
INDICATES THAT THE YOUTH
POPULATION HAS THE LOWEST VOTER
TURNOUT. OF ANY AGE DEMOGRAPHIC
THE TURNOUT FOR ELIGIBLE YOUTH
VOTERS WAS ONLY 28% FOR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GENERAL HERE IN
OUR STATE. ACA FOR WOULD CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE FIRST
TIME VOTERS MANY HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS FOR EXAMPLE AND BOOST
THE YOUTH VOTER TURNOUT BY
ALLOWING SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO
VOTE IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION
PROVIDED IN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION THAT THEY
WILL BE EIGHTEEN. BY THE TIME
OF THE GENERAL ELECTION STUDY
SHOWED THE VOTING IS HABIT
FORMING ONCE A PERSON VOTES
HERE SHE IS MORE LIKELY TO DO
SO AGAIN. EARLY INVOLVEMENT IN
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS FOR FIRST
TIME VOTERS SHOULD BE A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THIS REASON ALONE.
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD LAY THE
FOUNDATION A BILL THE VOTING
HAVE IT AT AN EARLY AGE
ALLOWING SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO
PARTICIPATE IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS WOULD COMPLEMENT. THE
CIVIC EDUCATION MANY RECEIVE IN
HIGH SCHOOL INCREASING THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE STUDENTS
BECOME LIFELONG VOTERS. THE
IDEA IS NOT A NEW ONE NEARLY
HALF OF STATES IN THE U. S.
BOTH RED AND BLUE STATES.
ALREADY ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PRIMARIES AND CAUCUSES FIRST
TIME VOTER SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
FULL ELECTION CYCLE THE
PRIMARY. AND GENERAL. THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA'S SIX THE TEMP. AT
THIS VERSION- AND I SHOULD SAY
THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
MULLINS INVOLVED- IN THIS
EFFORT. AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT IT HAS BEEN HEARD. ON
THE SENATE SIDE AND FOR THAT I
AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE MANY. GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE CA FOUR
AS WELL AS OUR PRIMARY SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. WE HAVE A
LEAD WITNESS DOCTOR MANY ROMERO
WITH A CALIFORNIA CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PROJECT WITH US OVER
THE PHONE BUT FIRST. I WOULD
LIKE TO UP OFFER MY COLLEAGUE
OR JOIN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF LOVE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FIRST CRUCIAL PART OF. THE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. AT
ALL THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
SOME COMMENTS ON THIS JOINT
MEASURE THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
SO IN AMMAN ONE QUICK QUESTION
USE YOUR MULTIPLE MULLINS'S IS
THAT. DOES INCLUDE YOUR FATHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN THAT IS
THE OTHER MULLIN IN REFERENCE
ATTENDED THIS. AND WAS A THIRTY
THREE YEAR. TEACHER OR THE- OF
WAS A RE. BUT AND I SAW TO GET.
TO YOUR AGO AND I HOPE YOU GET
MIGHT. VERY GOOD THANK YOU. IT
COULD ALSO BE- FOR THE
RESPECTIVE MOM FAMILY- TO HAVE
THIS. COME THIS DREAM. COME
TRUE FOR WISHIN- WITH RESPECT
TO THIS ISSUE AT HAND IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AS YOU MAY KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE ITERATIONS
OF THIS MEASURE. AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE COLLEGIALITY OF
ADVANCING THIS ISSUE. ALONG
WITH THE DESIRES OF THE SENATE
WE HAVE COMBINED OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN. PROVIDE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE WHICH IS SIMILAR BY THE
WAY AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. TO
SEVENTEEN OTHER STATES WHICH
ALREADY HAS. OF THIS ON THE
BOOKS AND BY THE WAY COLLEAGUES.
SEVENTEEN STATES INCLUDE
CONNECTICUT DELAWARE ILLINOIS
INDIANA KENTUCKY MAINE MARYLAND
TO CITY NEBRASKA NEW MEXICO
NORTH CAROLINA OHIO SOUTH
CAROLINA UTAH. VERMONT VIRGINIA
AND WEST VIRGINIA AS WELL SO
AGAIN. WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR AN
INCREASE VOTER PARTICIPATION.
AS IT IS OUR CIVIC DUTY. AND
FOCUS ON THE RESTORATION OF
ACTIVE STATES AND RE WRIST. ASK
FOR VOTE. THANK YOU. COMMAND
BOTH OF YOU. WORK VERY VERY
HARD VERY CLEVER DOUBLY. AND
YOUR COLLABORATION- AND YOUR
HARD WORK REALLY SERVICES
EXAMPLE FOR ALL OF US. GOOD
COULD BE DONE WE ALL. ARE A
COOPERATIVE. TOGETHER SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UP IN JUST A
SECOND. TURN TO YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS DOCTOR MINDY. REMAIN
WELL. FOR THE IF YOU LISTEN ON
PHONE. WE'RE PROVIDE THREE. TWO
SITE PORT YEAH OPPOSITION NEVER
GONE. UNDER THE. TURN TO THE
FALL WELL I AM. I'M THE SUPPORT
THE MEASURE IN A TOLL THAT THE
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF OTHERS WHO
ORGANISED THE MET AND SO THIS
WILL PASS OUT OF THIS I WANNA
LET FOLKS KNOW ON THE PHONE SO
THEY KNOW AHEAD OF WHY THIS
WHAT BASS. WHAT FUTURE OF. WHEN
YOU DO TESTIFY ON THE PHONE
YOU'LL BE PERMITTED TO GIVE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND AS POLLS THAT YOU'LL BE
SUPPORTING IF YOU'RE TESTIFYING
IN THE SUPPORT Q. AND OPPOSING
IF YOU'RE IN THE OPPOSITION
QUEUE. SO LET ME LET ME NOW
TURN TO OF THE MODERATOR AND-
MODERATE TO KEEP TELL ME IF
DOCTOR ROMERO WAS ON THE PHONE.
A DOCTOR MARROW IS ON THE LINE-
TUCKER MARYLAND OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME. TO
START I AM VERY SURGERY DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA DID HE TEACH MY
PROJECT AT USC AND FACULTY
THERE AND I'M- QUESTION I'D
HAVE TO FIND THOSE THAT WE
DON'T TAKE POSITIONS ON
SPECIFIC FELLOW- AS A
UNIVERSITY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION- BUT I AM HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE READER
CAN. REALLY HELP THAT THAT IN
THE CONVERSATION THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN I HAVEN'T SO TO BE
CAN. A LITTLE PARTY. IN LOW IN
OUR- THAT'S NO SURPRISE ANYONE
HERE HARD DEADLINE- IN
CALIFORNIA AND OF COURSE ACROSS
THE U. S. ANY GIVEN ELECTION. I
TURNOUT OF ELIGIBLE YOUNG
PEOPLE WILL SAY. AGE EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR AND THOSE WHO
ARE IT IS AN ELIGIBLE. AT
TRINITY TWENTY THIRTY FORTY TWO
PERCENTAGE POINTS LOWER THAN
OLDER AGE GROUP. IN THE PRIMARY
WE ARE BRAND NEW DATA THAT WE
CAN SHARE WE DIDN'T A RECENT
ANALYSIS OF THAT TWENTY TWENTY
MARCH PRIMARY. TURNOUT THEIR
OVERALL. FOR PRESS. FOR THE
TOTAL ELECTORATE ELIGIBLE BUT
FOR THOSE AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
TURNOUT WAS ONLY SIXTEEN
PERCENT. THAT BY THE WAY WITH A
DECREASE OVER THE MOST RECENT
FROM HER COLLECTION THAT TWENTY
SIXTEEN PRIMARY. DOWN BY ABOUT
A PERCENTAGE POINT. COMPARE
THAT TO. THAT 34% NUMBER FOR
EVERYBODY WHICH WAS A IN
INCREASED BY ABOUT FOUR
PERCENTAGE POINT TO EVERYBODY
INCREASED BUT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
DECREASED. IF WE LOOK AT
TURNOUT AT THE AGE SIXTY FIVE
CLASS. ELIGIBLE TURNOUT IN THE
PRIMARY WITH FIFTY SIX PERCENT-
AGAIN 16% PER YOUNG PEOPLE AGED
1822456% FOR THOSE OVER SIXTY
FIVE. AGAIN WORKING A FORTY
PERCENTAGE POINT. GAP BUT THERE
ARE IN THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
RIGHT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE
ARE REAL REASON FOR THESE
DISPARITIES. PATTERNS OF
DISPARITIES THAT WE SEE AND
THERE ARE ASKED WE CAN HATE.
ADDED SHE REFUSED TO REMOVE.
ASIAN AND OF COURSE- THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
A LOT IN THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
TRY TO DO THIS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE DONE-
WE KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE. ARE
LIKELY TO SHE GOT REACHING
EDUCATION MOBILIZATION ACT.
CANADA BUT BECAUSE OF THIS IS
MICHAEL IN TERMS OF AND THEN
NOT TURNING OUT. LACK OF
INFORMATION VOTERS BY
DEFINITION YOUR NEW AND
UNFAMILIAR AND THEREFORE
UNCERTAIN ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING. LACK OF COURSE THE
ROBUST CIVIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
WE'VE WONDERFUL ONE HUNDRED
JUST HEARD WONDERFUL TO THE
TEACHERS THAT ARE OUT THERE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE. A REALLY GREAT
BEST. BEST ARE. AT SIX
EDUCATION PROGRAM. AND THAT
PERHAPS MOST OF ALL. OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE OFTEN. FIND IT DIFFICULT
TO CONNECT. I THE PROCESS TO
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT THEY DON'T
YOU JERRY AT THE AUSTIN. IN THE
ACT OF BUILDING ITSELF THE CARE
VERY MUCH THAT NOT HAPPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY- INSANE FORMED AND
TING INVOLVED AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN. I WANT TO SEE A GREAT
IMPROVEMENT IN THE WORLD AROUND
THEM BUT THEY DON'T SEE ANY
OPTION HOW ACT BUILDING ITSELF
IS AN ACTIONABLE STEPS. TO GET
THERE. ON ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO TO INCREASE AT TENNESSEE AND
THIS IS WHERE NOW WE TURN TO
THE BILL. ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
INCREASE THE ONLY THING IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. SO THINGS
LIKE WE ALREADY KNOW RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN US THINGS LIKE MOCK
DEBATE THE MOCK ELECTION.
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL GO TO
REGISTER AND VOTE INCLUDING OF
COURSE IS HABIT FORMING WE KNOW
FROM. RESEARCH SO WE KNOW THAT
WE GET THEM YOUNG. OTHER MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO CONTINUE TO GO
TO THE LIFE COURSE. SOMETHING.
LIKE EIGHTEEN A FORMER. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. IT IS NOT MUCH
OF A LEAP TO SAY. WELL IF WE'RE
IF YOUNG PEOPLE COMING. PERSON
VOTE IN THE PRIMARY AND
DIRECTLY CONNECT THAT VOTE. TO
IMPLEMENTING THE BALLOT ON THE
GENERAL ELECTION. RIGHT THAT
CAN BE QUITE SUBSTANTIAL- AND
CERTAINLY CAN BE USED AS A TOOL
IMMOBILIZING AND- OUTREACH
EFFORTS OF YOUNG PEOPLE AS OF
TO OCCUR. SO I'LL LEAVE IT
THERE BUT- YOU KNOW THE
RESEARCH TELLS US HERE THAT
THIS COULD BE ANOTHER KEY TOOL.
FOR ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE AT THE ALL OF THESE
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE AND- TO GET
THEM TO. CREATE THAT HABIT
YOUNGER- THAT WILL CONTINUE TO.
RISE COURSE IN TERMS OF
POLITICAL PARTICIPATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU DOCTOR
MERYL. ALL RIGHT. WELL WE'LL-
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU TELL
ME IF OF FOLKS HAVE BEEN CUED
UP ON THE SUPPORT LINE. HELLO
IS ONLY IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AN UPPER WILL GIVE YOU A
NUMBER AND I WILL ANNOUNCE YOU
BY THAT NUMBER ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME IT
DOES LOO LIKE WE HAVE THREE
THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE. RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THEIR
LINES. ALL RIGHT I'LL GO FIRST
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU NUMBER AGAIN
MEMBERS MOLECULAR NOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA THE OF CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO NANCY IT'S NEAR ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
TO CALIFORNIA- ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ACA FOR THANKS.
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. ALRIGHT
LET US NOW TURN THE OPPOSITION
IS THEIR PRIMARY- OPPOSITION
WITNESS MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD. THREE MEMBERS ON THE
PHONE TO SEE IF THERE'S A
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS THAT
PERSONAL BE- FORTY THREE
MINUTES. HOW DO WE HAVE-
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
WELL MISTER MODERATOR IF
SOMEONE- SHOWS UP ON THE LINE
IN THE NEXT COUPLE MINUTES THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD GIVE THEM. THREE
MINUTES BUT- IT ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION. HOW LATE JIM IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR ON AGAIN I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD. HOUSE AND SAY
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SO MISTER MODERATOR I'M
GONNA TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF SOMEONE APPEARS ON
THE LINE OPPOSITION WE CAN COME
BACK TO THEM. BUT LET LET'S NOT
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMITTEE WITH
QUESTIONS. BUT I SEE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBER WITH QUESTIONS
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S TRIBUNAL GOOD
WORK OF THE JOINT AUTHORS.
WHO'VE DONE SUCH PERSUASIVE JOB
THAT WE HAVE KNOWN IN
OPPOSITION AND NO QUESTIONS SO.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE. WELL WAIT
A MINUTE ONE SECOND I THINK WE
NEED A MOTION. YES SENATE STERN
MODE YOU HAVE A QUESTION I DO I
DO WANT TO MAKE A MOTION AND
LET ME ADD TO MY MOTION. A WORD
OF GRATITUDE TO- THE JOINT
AUTHORS HERE FOR THEIR- EFFORTS
MOVING THIS ISSUE FORWARD. ENDS.
ON ENFRANCHISEMENT OF A- VOICE
THAT'S BEEN SILENCE TOO LONG
WHEN YOU DON'T LEARN CIVIC
HABIT. IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN IT'S
JUST A HYPOTHETICAL THAT
GOVERNMENT CLASS WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT VOTING IN THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT BUT IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MAKE SENSE AND YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO LEAVE HOME AND-
DRAG YOURSELF. YOUR COMMUNITY
THAT ACTUALLY IS WHERE VOTING
MAKES THE MOST SENSE WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE A THAT VESTER
ROMERO TAUGHT ME WHEN YOU BUILD
THAT CIVIC CABIN IN YOU GET A
STRONGER COUNTRY SAID THANK YOU
FOR. GIVING US A PATHWAY HERE.
AND WITH THAT I'D MAKE A MOTION.
RIGHT MOVED CERTAINLY MEMBERS
MULLIN AND LOWERED LIKE CLOSE.
BUT JUST BAKER SAID A COLLEAGUE
OF FOR THE COMMENTS AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH BOTH MR LOWERED
MYSELF YOUR CONSULTATION ON
THIS ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
LEADS OF SO MANY ELECTIONS
ACCESS ISSUES. IS REALLY BEHIND
THE CURVE WHEN IT COMES THE
YOUTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AS TIME
FOR US TO CATCH UP PLEASE JOIN
US IN PURSUING WITH SO MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE ALLOW
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS THE RIGHT
TO VOTE PRIMARY ELECTIONS
PROVIDED THEY'LL BE EIGHTEEN BY
THE GENERAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SOME OF OUR
LOW. DID UP ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
OF NO FOR THE DEBATE IF- MISTER
SECTOR IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
PASSED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG. LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE STERN HI STERN HI ALL
RIGHT KERN OTIS THREE TO ONE WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN HERE
FOR A LITTLE WHILE- TO AFFORD
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE ALL
RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIMILAR MEMBER LAW- SO REMEMBER
MULLIN. WE HAVE NOW A CA ELEVEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR MEMBERS WE
ARE TRULY EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WHILE THE
KOBE PANDEMIC CONTINUES WITH NO
END IN SIGHT SORT OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND
LOOMING WILDFIRE SEASON. I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT A CA ELEVEN AS
A COMPROMISE MEASURE TO REPLACE
THE MEASURE WHICH HAS QUALIFY
FOR THE NOVEMBER BALLOT
ENSURING THAT FUNDING FOR FIRE
PROTECTION AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVENUES ARE PROTECTED ALLOWING
FOR FLEXIBILITY AND REFORM IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
FORMULAS WHILE LEAVING THE
PROTECTIONS OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN INTACT. THIS MEASURE
CONTAINS SEVERAL PROVISIONS
INTENDED TO INCREASE THE STOCK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
AVAILABLE HOUSING AND PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS TO VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS IN THE HOUSING
MARKET WELL CREATING PROTECTED
FUNDING FOR UNDERFUNDED FIRE
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INSURING THAT COUNTIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE EQUAL
AND EQUITABLE FUNDING THROUGH
ITS PROVISIONS PROPOSITIONS
FIFTY EIGHTY ONE NINETY THREE
CREATED A MECHANISM FOR PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS TO TRANSFER
THEIR HOME FOR THEIR CHILDREN
HOMES HAVING THEIR PROPERTY TAX
REASSESSED SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THOSE PROPOSITIONS THESE
EXCLUSIONS HAVE BEEN ROUTINE
WITH EXPLOITED BY WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS AS A TOOL FOR ANY
ONE HERIDAS THIRD OR FOURTH
HOME WITHOUT THAT PROPERTY.
THREE SEC PCA ELEVEN WILL
PROTECT THE FAMILY TRANSFERS
BUT A FAMILY MEMBERS GOING TO
TREAT THE NEW PROPERTY AS A
PRIMARY. IT WOULD CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE FOR PATIENT HOMES AND
OTHER USES THAT TO NOT INCLUDE
A PRIMARY RESIDENCE BY CLOSING
THOSE LOOPHOLES THE STATE WILL
BE ABLE TO GENERATE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR FIRE
PROTECTION AGENCY SERVICES
OTHER CRITICAL LOCAL PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THE HOMELESS THAT
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ARE TO HELP FUND DEVELOPERS OF
AFFORD HOW PROJECTS THROUGH THE
STATE. SEE A SEVEN OPEN UP TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF NEW OUT FOR
RENTERS FIRST TIME HOME OWNERS.
BY ALLOWING THOSE THAT QUALIFY
AND WOULD LIKE TO SELL THEIR
HOME BUT CAN'T DO TO BEING
UNABLE TO AFFORD THE PROPERTY
TAXES ON A NEW HOMES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF
INCREASED DEMAND ACA ELEVEN
WILL SPUR HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE DEMAND FOR
HOUSING STATEWIDE. AC A ELEVEN
CONTINUES TO PROTECT SENIORS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
FAMILIES AND VICTIMS OF
WILDFIRE BY LIMITING PROPERTY
TAX INCREASES ON PRIMARY
RESIDENCE RESIDENCES. ACA
ELEVEN ALSO REMOVES UNFAIR
LOCATION RESTRICTIONS FOR
PROPOSITION SIXTY AND NINETY
THUS ALLOWING THOSE THAT ARE
QUALIFIED TO MOVE TO ANYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND RETAIN THEIR
BASE YOUR VALUE. REMOVING THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WILL ALLOW OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS TO
MOVE CLOSER TO FAMILY OR
MEDICAL CARE TO A SENIOR
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY OR OR TO
REPLACE A DAMAGED HOME ANYWHERE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN A
CA ELEVEN PROTECTS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS. TO
PASS THE FAMILY HOME TO THEIR
CHILDREN ENSURING THAT CAN
AFFORD TO MOVE INTO THAT HOME
AS PRIMARY RESIDENCE THE NEW
FUNDING GENERATED BY A CA
ELEVEN. WILL PLAY A ROLE IN OUR
STATES ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
LONG TERM REVENUE ESTIMATED TO
BE OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. IT'S ON THE TEND OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
HISTORICALLY UNDERFUNDED FIRE
DISTRICT TO BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITY TO ALSO PROVIDE
SOME OF MY FUNDING. TO CAL. IN
SUPPORT CAL. VIRUS WHICH- LINES
OF HOPE. AND MILLION OF LIVES.
IN FINALLY THE MEMBER PROVIDES
LOCAL REVENUE CAN CITIES AND
SPECIAL. BY GENERATE STABLE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE FOR EVERY
COUNTY ACROSS THE STATE AT A
TIME WHEN COUNTY IS NEEDED MOST
OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE AC
ELEVEN PROTECTS COUNTIES
LOSS. FOR THOSE THAT MOVE TO
ANOTHER COUNTY BY ESTABLISHING
AN OFFSET FUND WHICH WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL REVENUE
PRODUCTOR TEXAN YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT. TO ENSURE LOCAL
GENERAL FUND STABILITY WITH ME
ON THE PHONE TODAY BRIAN RICE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. AND
JEAN RAD SIX PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
PRESIDENT UP WITHIN. AND WE
HAVE SOME OTHER- EXPERTS ON THE
LINE AS WELL WHO ARE AVAILABLE
TO TALK ABOUT THE PARTICULARS
WITH REGARD TO THE FUNDING
FORMULAS IF THOSE QUESTIONS
pMEMBER MULLIN BEFORE WE BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES LET LET ME JUST.
AT THAT- DO THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY MRS WILL EARLIER BUT
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES- NEEDS
THE SUPPORT SO I GUESS THREE
MINUTES OF THE OPPOSITION SIDE
GETS THREE MINUTES ALL OF THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. ENDED THEIR
POSITION ALTHOUGH IF YOU'RE IN
THE SUPPORT TO WE WILL ASSUME
YOU SUPPORT IF YOU'RE IN THE-
OPPOSE Q. WILL ASSUME YOU
OPPOSE I UNDERSTAND THAT-
MISTER RICE IS ON THE PHONE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD-
OPEN MISTER RICE'S LINE AND TO
BE FOLLOWED BY MISTER JEAN
RIGHT SICK IS THAT CORRECT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MALL. MR READ
SICK AS YOUR SECOND IS THE
SECOND ONE THIS IS A RIGHT. I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU BUILD THE REPEAT THAT
I SAID I SHOULD I SHOULD NOTE I
WEAR HEARING AIDS IN THIS IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO DRIVE IN
FREE HERE SO SAYS THAT MORE TO
HEAR YOUR TWO WITNESSES ARE
MISTER RICE AND MISTER RIGHT
SICKIS THAT CORRECT. MS MS
RATS SICK FROM THE REALTORS
JUST READ SICK I APOLOGIZE ALL
RIGHT SO BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES- MISTER
MODERATOR IF EITHER OF THEM.
ARE ON THE PHONE IF YOU. ON THE
LINE. WE HAVE BOTH WITNESSES ON
THE LINE AND BOTH THEIR LINES
ARE OPEN. ALL RIGHT. WHEN WE
START WITH MISTER REISS. BRIAN
RACE- AUDIBLE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BROWN RICE
THAT PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS I
REPRESENT MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND. PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMS PERSONNEL
IN THE MOST PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE HE ELEVEN EIGHTY ELEVEN DID
IMPORTANT COMPROMISED WILL
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESULTING
IN MARKET VALUE REASSESSMENT.
AC ELEVEN HELPS CORRECT THE
FIFTY YEAR PROBLEM WITH THE
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM IN
SUPPORT OF UNDER FUNDED FIRE
DISTRICTS. AT ELEVEN CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE CURRENTLY. EXPLOITED
BY THE WEALTHY TO AVOID PAYING
PROPERTY TAXES ON VACATION
HOMES AT THIS TIME BE ELEVEN
PROTECTS THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT HERE DE AND LEAVES THE
PROTECTIONS OF PROP THIRTEEN
INTACT. THE MEASURE ALSO- ADDS
REIMBURSEMENT PROTECTION FOR
COUNTIES INTELLIGIBLE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO GUARD AGAINST ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF THE
PORTABILITY PROVISIONS. THERE
ARE NO WINNERS AND LOSERS ONLY
WINNERS AND WINTERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE INCREASE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE WILL
CREATE NET GAINS IN STATE
REVENUE WHICH WILL FREE UP
MONEY FOR THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
RESPONSE FUND. REVENUES FROM
THE FUND WILL GO TO CAL FIRE IN
UNDERFUNDED FIRE DISTRICTS
PROVIDING CRITICAL RESPONSE TO
AREAS VULNERABLE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. AC ELEVEN IS A
REASONABLE COMPROMISE THAT
BETTER PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR
BOATERS THEN THE CURRENT
MEASURE THAT WILL APPEAR ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT. IT GENERATES
CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDING FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES AND WILD FIRE
RESPONSE AND IT CLOSES IN
UNFAIR LOOPHOLE WITHOUT
UNDERMINING PROP NINETY EIGHT
OR PROP THE THIRTEEN- ARBEL
TURN MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
MISTER REISS MISTER SICK YOU
YOU HAVE A ONE MINUTE INTO FIVE
SO. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEAN RAFIC AND I AM THE
TWENTY TWENTY PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS REPRESENTING OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA TASTING YEARS AND
SEVERELY DISABLED INDIVIDUAL.
FEELING TRAPPED IN THEIR HOMES
WITH FAMILY SUPPORT AND MUCH
NEEDED MEDICAL CARE OUT OF
REACH. IT SHOULD WORSEN DURING
THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA Y.
BARS I REFER DISPLACING
FAMILIES FROM THEIR HOMES THESE
FAMILIES ARE THEN BURDENED WITH
HIGHER PROPERTY TAXES. WHEN OUR
FIRST FORCED TO MOVE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE VICTIMS OF A
NATURAL DISASTER. G. A. R. IS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ACA ELEVEN WHICH
SEEKS TO HELP THESE
CALIFORNIANS. ACA ELEVEN IS THE
ALTERNATIVE TO OUR NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT
PROPOSITION IT HAD GAINED A
MORE ROBUST COALITION OF
SUPPORT AND INCLUDES MORE
BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIANS DID
NEED. SPECIFICALLY ACA ELEVEN
STRENGTHENED PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN WHILE GENERATING. MUCH
NEEDED REVENUE PER COUNTY
CITIES AND HISTORICALLY UNDER
UNDER FUNDED FIRE DISTRICTS. AC
IS AN IMPORTANT BIPARTISAN
MEASURE THAT IT GARNERED
SUPPORT FROM LABOR BUSINESS AND
AGRICULTURAL GROUPS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHT ELEVEN.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE KAREEM
TO RECIEVE THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE A. R. AND
KURT ANITA. PARTNER AND NIELSEN
MARKERS SHIMMER MARKETS MORE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS RIGHT SICK
ALL RIGHT- WE WE'RE NOW GOING
TO- INQUIRE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE CHAMBER- OTHER WITH THIS IS
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AGAIN IT'LL BE JUST NAME
AFFILIATION. AND YOUR POSITION.
SAYING NO WITNESSES AND THE
CHAMBER TO TESTIFYING OR TO
PROVIDE THEIR SUPPORT- THIS
BOMBER DID YOU WANT TO. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PRETTY WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IS
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
THEY SHOULD ARRIVE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- IN ROOM TWO FORTY
THE OVERFLOW ROOM LET'S SEE. IT
IS A GHOST IN ROOM TWO TWENTY
FORTY SO NOW WE'LL TURN TO THE
LINES TELEPHONE LINES. OF ONCE
AGAIN JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION-
MISTER MODERATOR OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS CUED UP ON THE
PHONE LINE. THEN LATER GERMAN
ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN YOU'LL
BE PROVIDED A NUMBER AND THEN
YOU WILL BE ANNOUNCED FOR THAT
NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT. HEY IT
DOES LOOK LIKE WE HAVE THREE
THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE. A FIRST
WE CAN GO TO NUMBER TWENTY ONE
OF TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS ROSA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO NUMBER
THIRTY THREE OF THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH REDUCE THAT THE ASIAN IN
THE COURT. THANK YOU. YEAH WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN SUPPORT SO
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY.
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS MATTHEW ARGROVE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND TODAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA ELEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONCE YOU HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WILL NOT NOT TURN TO
OPPOSITION- IF THERE'S A
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
IDENTIFY HIM OR HER. I'M NOT
AWARE OF A PRIMARY UPSIDE
WITNESSES IF ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WHICH IS TO
IDENTIFY. THEMSELVES AS SUCH
THEY SHOULD DO SO NOW. ALL
RIGHT- MISTER MODERATOR IT IF
SOMEONE APPEARS HERE- AS WE GO
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
IF YOU LET US KNOW BUT FIRST
LET'S TAKE OTHERS ON THE LINE
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
ELSE ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. AND
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. BUT WE DO HAVE ONE IN
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN WE JUST HAD. HI
AND MY NAME IS DIRTY KERN AND
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. AND
WE'RE NOT OFFICIALLY OPPOSES WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS WITHTHE
MEASURE- WE UNDERSTAND THAT AC
ELEVEN IS THAT REPLACE THE
MEASURE FOR THE REALTORS
MEASURE THAT QUALIFY FOR THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT. AND HE OPPOSES
THAT MEASURE- AND WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
COMPROMISE WE'RE STILL VERY
CONCERNED THAT WILL RESULT IN A
LOT SAID PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND I
THINK THEY APPROACH SAYING
YOU'RE BEING HOUSING AND CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA IS A BIT
DISINGENUOUS WHERE YOU'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THE COST OF HOUSING
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY AND REDUCING
THE PROPERTY TAX VALUE WE USED.
TO SUPPORT THOSE COMMUNITIES.
LIBRARIES PARKS AND SO THE OF
HOUSING IS STILL OUTRAGEOUS
YEAH WE'RE REDUCE. THE AMOUNT
THAT OF FUNDING THAT COMES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT
THOSE COMMUNITIES. I THINK ALSO
YOU KNOW I'M A POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJOR NOT A MATH MAJOR
SO THE FUNDING FORMULA THAT IS
CREATED AND THEN- AND SEEN-
CONFUSING I'M NOT REALLY SURE
THAT IN THAT SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT- I
THINK WE ARE A LITTLE
CONCERNED. THAT 75% OF THE
REVENUE GOES TO FIRES DISTRICT
OR FIRE SUPPORT AND 15% GOES TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AGAIN EITHER CONCERN
OR NOT OPPOSED TO THAT MEASURE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
TRYING TO GET A MEASURE THAT
IS- WORSTTALENT BUT- AGAIN AND
THEY'RE BOTH VERY PROBLEMATIC
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM OF ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSITION. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN OPPOSITION-
NEXT WE GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JON COUPEAUX PRESIDENT OF
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION- WHAT WE LIKED THE
PORTABILITY PROVISIONS- WE
SHOULD NOT SACRIFICE THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS OF THE
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFER. FOR
THE SAKE OF THE PORTABILITY
PROVISIONS THIS IS A NET. TAX
INCREASE PROPERTY TAX INCREASE-
OF AT LEAST A BILLION DOLLARS
AND WE THINK THAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME AND SO
WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU MR
KOPPEL. RIGHT ANYBOY ELSE.
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NOBODY ELSE IN OUR QUEUE
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEE MR HERTZBERG IS
MIKE IS UP WILL GO TO MISTER
HERTZBERG THEIR CENTER
HERTZBERG IN DECEMBER NIELSEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE ARE HERE FOR TO TELL TO SING
ON. MISTER CHAIRMAN HI I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
BECAUSE- I THINK THAT IS WE
DEVELOP PUBLIC POLICY. WE ARE
ENGAGED IN A SIGNIFICANT
BALANCING ACT. OF A LOT OF
COMPETING INTERESTS. AND AS I
SEE THE MEASURE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLINS MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY.
IT IS FROM MY EXPERIENCE A VERY
ELEGANT SOLUTION TO SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT NEAR TERM AND LONG
TERM CHALLENGES MISTER CHAIR.
IN MY THINKING IS THIS.
PORTABILITY HAS MYSTICAL PAUL
MENTIONED AND IS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONS SOMETHING IS VERY
IMPORTANT. WE'VE GOT A
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS
WHERE WE HAVE FOLKS WHO BOUGHT
THEIR HOMES PRIOR TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE HAVE A VERY LOW TAX
BASE. MANY OF THOSE HOMEOWNERS
HAVE PAID OFF THEIR MORTGAGES
BUT ARE AFRAID TO MOVE BECAUSE
IF THEY MOVE TO ANOTHER COUNTY
OR MOVE SOMEPLACE ELSE THAT
THERE CAN BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE. RETIRED PRIEST IS THEY
MAY HAVE WATER HOMES IN
NINETEEN. SEVENTY FIVE FOR
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TODAY IT'S WORTH EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND EVEN
THOUGH THEIR CURRENT PROPERTY
HE HAS IS WORTH MUCH MORE THAN
WHEN THEY BOUGHT IT. THERE'S A
DEEP FEAR. THAT THIS ISSUE
RELATING TO BUYING A NEW HOME
I'VE TALKED TO MANY SENIORS WHO
ARE CONCERNED. AND WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THIS MEASURE. THE
AUTHOR I THINK A PRETTY
ELEGANTLY. IS ALLOW FOR PEOPLE
AMONG ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
TO REALIZE THAT BENEFIT
SECONDLY. BECAUSE OF THIS
INTERGENERATIONAL ISSUE THERE'S
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO ARE OLDER
FOLKS THAT HAVE AT THE HOMES
FOR A LONG TIME. AND WE PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW YOUNG
FAMILIES TO MOVE INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND SO THE
ESTIMATE I'VE SEEN AS THIS MAY
RESULT IN AS MANY AS SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NEW HOMES. BOTH
DEALING WITH THE HOUSING ISSUE
FOR FAMILIES DEALING WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT RETIREES HAVE
THAT ARE IN THEIR HOMES AND
WORRIED. DESPERATELY ABOUT
FACING A LARGER TAX BILL
SOLUTION NUMBER ONE. SOLUTION
NUMBER TWO IN THE LARGER
CITIES. WHERE ARMED. A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
COUNTIES OF THE TAX REVENUE
COMES FROM PROPERTY TAX AS A
RESULT OF THESE NEW SALES OF
PROPERTY THAT MIGHT HAVE ONLY
GOTTEN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR IN PROPERTY TAX HOW MIGHT
TEN OR FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR WHICH DRAMATICALLY HELPS
PROVIDING FOR THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET IN CITIES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
MORE. OUT OF. ELEGANT SOLUTION
NUMBER TWO. NUMBER THREE WITH
RESPECT TO FIRE FIGHTING
DISTRICTS THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT FIRE IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
SEEN HISTORICALLY. WE ARE
FACING SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
MISTER CHAIR ON CLIMATE CHANGE
THE NATURE AND THE EXTENT. WHO
ORDINARILY DESTRUCTIVE POWER
WE'RE SEEING NOW IS RESULT OF
FIRES WE NEED IS A STATE TO
PRIORITIZE BOTH THE ISSUES OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND PREVENTION
ON THE ONE HAND A YOU KNOW THAT
PEACE BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE THAT
LEVEL. OF SUPPORT DEALING WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE ELEGANT SOLUTION
NUMBER THREE. FOR FIREFIGHTERS
ARE PART OF THIS LARGER
COMMUNITY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
DELIVERABLES WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED A VERY SIGNIFICANT
CONVERSATION RECENTLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE IDEA PUBLIC
SAFETY WHAT DOES IT MEAN
FIREFIGHTERS A TO PARAMEDIC TEN
WHAT DO THEY'RE DEALING WITH
FOLKS AND DRUG THROUGH THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE HOMELESS
TO BE. ONE OF OUR FAITH WITH
RESPECT TO POLICE. L. NUMBER
FOUR NUMBER FIVE A LOT OF THESE
FIRE DISTRICTS THAT WERE FORMED
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN AND DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF IRAQ FOR THE
LIKE HAVE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AND THIS PROVIDES
THAT LEVEL OF CERTAINTY IN THE
CONSTITUTION AS THE AUTHOR HAS
SAID. THAT'S CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA ELEGANT SOLUTION
NUMBER FIVE SO I STAND HERE
TODAY. STRONG SUPPORT OF MR
MULLINS MEASURE TOGETHER WITH
THE OTHER JOINT AUTHORS. MR
MAZEN A- SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND BURKE AND I
BELIEVE- BUT THE MISTER GRAY
SOON TO BE ADDED I BELIEVE IS
THE JOINT AUTHORS TOGETHER WITH
THE OTHER SEVENTEEN CO AUTHORS
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY WHO HAVE STANDING TALL
WITH RESPECT TO MAKING A CAR
MAIS ON THIS ISSUE. AND THE
LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE. IS
THAT WE HAVE THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY DIRECT DEMOCRACY THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS. THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS HAS BEEN PUT
INTO THE CONSTITUTION MORE THAN
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO TO GIVE
VOICE TO FOLKS. BUT WE A FEW
YEARS AGO REINSTITUTED WHAT WAS
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION CALL THE INDIRECT
INITIATIVE. AND THE OTHER
DIRECT INITIATIVE ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE DAYS
BEFORE THE TIME OF THE. BEFORE
THE ELECTION TO ACTUALLY REACH
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
PROPONENTS TO PULL OFF THE
MEASURE AND SO THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS WHICH IS GREAT I THINK
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IS TO TAKE
WHAT WITH REALTORS AND OTHERS
HAVE PUT ON THAT'S ON THE
BALLOT NOW AND COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION THAT
ARTICULATES AND SETS FORTH THE
ELEGANT SOLUTIONS THAT I
MENTIONED. IS FOR THE REASON IS
A BIG DEAL THIS IS A REALLY BIG
DEAL IT TAKES A LOT OF
IMPORTANT BOXES AND POLICY IF
CALIFORNIA VITAL IMPORTANT
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIANS IN THE
NORTHERN MOST NORTHERN PART OF
THE STATE. AND THE MOST
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE. AND
ALLOWS US IN CALIFORNIA TO LEAD
THE WAY ON THE HOUSING AND
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY IN PUBLIC
SAFETY AND A BROAD SWATH OF
ISSUES. AND THAT'S THE REASON
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANTED
TO. EXPRESS MY THINKING WITH
RESPECT TO INSTEAD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE JOINT AUTHORS OF
THIS MEASURE I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG CENTER NIELSEN. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN I RICE VERY SHARPLY
IN OPPOSITION. ACTUALLY NOT
POSITION. I RAN FOR THE FIRST
TIME FOR THE STATE LEGISLATURE
THE YEAR PROPOSITION THIRTEEN.
BELIEVING IN THE AGREE JUST.
RIGHT THAT IN THE POST THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IT WAS A
PROPERTY TAX REBELLION EIGHT
TAX WITH BILLION. THE PRESENT
CENTER NIELSEN ONE SECOND YOUR
MICROPHONE. WHATEVER REASON IS
NOT WORKING LET'S MAYBE I'M NOT
SPEAK INTO IT HOW ABOUT THAT WE
GO. VERY GOOD CENTER HEY I THEN
BEGIN AGAIN. I CAME IN.
ORIGINALLY THAT'S A PROFOUND
SUPPORT THE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. IT WAS A FRESH RATED
RESPONSE OF CITIZENS FED UP
WITH GOVERNMENT. TAKE IN THEIR
INCOME AND THE PROPERTIES.
MAKING UP MORE AND MORE OF AN
ONEROUS BURDEN. FOR THEM.
ELEVEN CALIFORNIA NOW THAT'S
HAPPENED YET AGAIN TODAY BUT
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE BEFORE.
THEY ROSE UP IN THIS PROPERTY
TAX REBELLION THE PROP THIRTEEN
REBELLION. SHOP THE NATION. AND
HAS MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE. IN
KEEPING PROPERTY. IN THE HANDS
A BEAUTIFUL OWNERS. CHECK SO
MUCH THE BILL THAT HERITAGE AND
LEGACY. AND ALSO TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS WOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. NOW THIS. TO HELP
THOSE ERRORS. WELL YEAH IT DOES
I GUESS BUT HOW MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN. LIVE REALLY REALLY
CLOSE TO US HOW MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN WATER THAT INHABIT
THAT DWELLING. THE THEIR
PARENTS OR GRANDPARENTS UNCLES
OR WHOEVER RECEIVED SOME
PROPERTY TAX BENEFIT FROM.
BECAUSE TO REAP THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PLUGGING OF A LOOPHOLE.
THEY MUST MOVE. WHAT ARE SOME
DO NOT WANT TO THE MUSTER FOR
GOOD THERE'S A CURRENCY. IN
TRADING IF YOU WILL. THESE
BENEFITS. I WOULD ARGUE IT'S
FIXING SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
BROKEN IS A TAX INCREASE. EVEN
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S TO
COST IT OUT THE INITIATIVE THAT
WILL BE ON THE BALLOT. EXACT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR TAX INCREASE.
THIS IS AKIN TO THAT. IN A LONG
TERM. AND YOU KNOW WE USE SOME
OF THE FAMOUS NEW WORDS OF THE
DAY. UNDER UNDER. WELL STATE
EVERYBODY'S WEALTHY THAT WE
DON'T LIKE THAT THERE THE EVIL
PEOPLE. WELL YOU KNOW. A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALSWHO ARE NOT WEALTHY.
CAN BE OWNING A BENEFITING AND
TAX ABOUT THIRTEEN TAX BENEFIT
FROM A ONE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPERTY. THAT DOESN'T. MEAN
THEY ARE WEALTHY. AND WE'RE THE
A SCORN. THAT HAVE IN THEIR
PROPERTY THE VALUE. NO. THIS IS
NOT A LOCAL. THE PROVISIONS AND
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN WERE
INTENDED. PURPOSEFUL AN
ANTICIPATORY OF THINGS THAT
WOULD GO ON IN THE FUTURE. SO
WE'RE GONNA TRUST THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIX IT. WELL
GUESS WHAT FOR DECADES. UP
UNTIL NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
THE LEGISLATURE DIDN'T DO A
DOGGONE THING. EXCEPT MAKE IT
WORSE. COMES PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
LEGISLATURE VOILA. GOT IT.
COMES BEFORE US SB ONE. WHICH
WAS THE ALTERNATIVE THE
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. SO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
COULD NOT THEIR BREASTS AND SAY
WE FIX THE PROBLEM. THE FOLKS
DIDN'T BY ACT. PROP ONE FOR A
SB ONE DID NOT PREVAIL EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS PASSED. AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR IS
OBVIOUSLY THE INITIATIVE. THE
PRESIDENT. RIGHT PLEASE SHOW
THE PEOPLE SAW WHAT IT WAS A
RUSE. NOW I WILL ARGUE THAT
THERE IS AN ELEMENT OF THAT
ROUTE IN THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE. SOME BODIES I HAVE NO
DOCUMENTATION EVIDENCES BUT- A
LONG HISTORY OF WATCHING THESE
SAYINGS. AND PROTECTOR THAT
PROP THIRTEEN EXPERIENCE. THEY
FEEL THEY CAN HEAD THAT
INITIATIVE OFF. BY THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF WORK. I
DON'T THINK IT WILL. I THINK
THE CITIZENS ARE GOING TO BE
SMART ENOUGH TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON. EMBELLISHMENTS
IN HERE- BOY WE'RE GOING TO
HELP THE FIREFIGHTERS. JOHN I'M
LEVEL SDOT SUPPORTER OF
FIREFIGHTERS THAN THIS BUILDING
OF ONE OF THE FIRST NOT JUST
THAT OUR DRIVER VAN. FOR GOOD
REASON I RIVER JUST NINETEEN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND YOU
CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE HOW MANY
FIRES. I'VE HAD THE- BRAIN OF
DEALING WITH OVER THESE DECADES
YOU BET. INCLUDING THE MOST
SERIOUS ONE EVER. PARADISE
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE GONNA TAKE
CARE. OF THOSE FIREFIGHTERS IN
THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND
CLEANING UP THE FIRES IN THE
FOREST AND WILD LANDS THAT ARE
SOURCING. SO MANY. OF THESE.
TERRIBLE DEVASTATING FIVE. YES
IT MIGHT LOOK ARTFUL IN.
POSITIVE THAT WE'RE HELP. THESE
FAMILY. I DO NOT THINK THAT WE
WILL. FOR FORTY TWO YEARS
VARIOUS AND SUNDRY ENTITIES
HAVE PRIDE. THE UNDERMINE.
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. AND
THAT'S ALL THAT THIS IS. UNDER
MY AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET MORE
MONEY FOR GOVERNMENT I ASK
WHOEVER MAYBE LISTENING OUT
THERE. I DO NOT THINK THE
MAJORITY OF YOU ARE REALLY
ANXIOUS. TO GIVE MORE OF YOUR
HARD EARNED DOLLARS. THE
GOVERNOR. YOU EXPECT GOVERNMENT
TO DELIVER FIRE AND POLICE
SERVICES WELL I GUESS WERE
TRYING TO UNDO ALL POLICE
SERVICES NOW BUT- YOU KNOW I
THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. THAT
THAT OUGHT TO BE A PRIORITY. ON
QUESTION. AND THESE FIRES A
REMINDER THIS. OF SUCH. BUT
LET'S GET BACK THEN TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL POINT. THIS BUT A
BILLION DOLLAR TAX INCREASE
FICTION I WON'T EVEN SAY
PURPORTED. EYELASH LOOPHOLES.
THAT FOR FORTY TWO YEARS HAVE
NOT BROUGHT. GOVERNMENT TO A
CHINESE. REMEMBER THE GLOOM AND
DOOM MURDERS A PROP THIRTEEN
THE WHOLE WORLD. AND THEN BORN
AGAIN PROP THIRTEEN PEOPLE. THE
DAY AFTER IT WAS AMUSING. TO
WATCH. THE VOLUME OF THE
RHETORIC SAYING HOW GREAT THIS
WAS. I BRING OF CURRENT OR MORE
CURRENT. PROP ONE THE RAINY DAY
FUND. ALL MY YEARS HERE. UP
UNTIL THAT MEASURE. SURVIVOR OF
THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO THE
CITIZENS. AND FISH THEY
SUPPORTED. THE RAINY DAY FUND.
AT ALL OF SOME OF THE SAME
PARTIES THAT ARE. HAVING THIS
IDEA HERE NOW. PULLING IN FOR
IT. LOW BOY THAT WASN'T GOING
TO WORK. NOT AT ALL. PROP ONE
TAKING ONE AND A HALF PERCENT
OFF THE TOP OF OUR BUDGET EVERY
YEAR AND PUTTING IT ASIDE AND
NOT SPENT SOME BAIT I. THE
SHORTAGE OF CALIFORNIA THE
TAXPAYERS- THEY'RE NOT THAT.
THAT MONEY SHOULD BE SPENT.
WELL. HERE WE ARE IN ONE OF THE
MOST TOUGH BUDGET PROBLEMS EVER.
AND WHAT DID WE HAVE THE
EMINENT LIST OF THOSE WHO WORK
SO HARD FOR PROP ONE. AND I
GET. ON THE CREDIT FOR SIGNING
THAT. PUTTING ON THE BALLOT.
BREAK EVERY SO OFTEN THE PAIN
OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. ISIS.
DELIVER LOOK AT THE ASHES.
COLIN LOOPHOLES FOR. WHATEVER
YOU WANNA CALL AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. THESE WHAT I
CONSIDER THE FRANCHISE OF THE
VOTERS IN THE CITIZENS AND THE
PROPERTY OWNERS. TO BE ABLE TO
DO WITH THEIR PROPERTY. WITHIN
LIMITS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
I'M GOING TO URGENT CONTINUE TO
ARGUE FOR VOTE. AND IF THAT
MEASURE DOES PASSED ON THE
BALLOT. BRADLEY I'M GONNA HAVE
TO LAUGH. IN SCORN THOSE WHO
GOT INTO THE BAD. THINKING THAT
THEIR LIVES WOULD BE SAVED IF
THEY GAVE AN ALTERNATIVE. SO
THAT PROPOSITION. BOB THIRTEEN
HAS WORKED AS IT WAS FOR FORTY
TWO YEARS. I PRAY IT WILL
CONTINUE. TO SELL WORK AND
SERVE THE CITIZENS FOR ANOTHER
FORTY TWO YEARS I AM URGING A
OVER. THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN ANY
OTHER. STERN YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MORE CLEAR FIVE
QUESTION VERY. IMPRESSED WITH
THE DIPLOMACY EFFORT THAT
SEALED IT THIS MEASURE AND A
IT'S A REMARKABLE FEAT. SO HATS
OFF TO THE TEAM THAT PUT THIS
TOGETHER MY QUESTION IS MORE IN
THE MECHANICS AND I'M WONDERING
MAYBE IF I DO YOU. MULLIN OR
YEAR- MAYBE ONE YEAR WITNESSES
BUT JUST. THE HOW THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ISSUE WORKS AND- WHY
DID WHY THE FUNDING ISSUE IF
YOU COULD JUST SORT OF
ELIMINATE SIR MAY MY MAIN NO
BUT- HOW THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
LAID OUT ACROSS THE STATE AND
WHY ARE THEY SORT OF CHRONIC
UNDER TWENTY. ONE IS THERE IS A
HISTORY OF LEFT IN THERE ABOUT
THE CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING OF THE
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICTS- I'M
GONNA TURN YOU. OF MY FIRE
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON
THAT IF CHRISTIE IS. AVAILABLE
TO THAT END NO CAN'T SEE BE
MISSED BY HERE OR OTHERS.
FORMER YOU ARE. CERTAINLY
MISTER GERM. I THINK WITH IN
SOME OF THE TESTING OF FROM
YOUR COLLEAGUE THAT SPECIAL ARE
FORMED UNDER SPECIFIC ACTS IN
THE CODE. AND THEIR PROPERTY
TAX ALLOTMENT HAS EVERYTHING TO
DO WITH A PROPERTY TAX
ALLOTMENT THEYRECEIVE PRIOR TO
THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN DO YOU HAVE MANY FIRED
IN CALIFORNIA- WHO IS THE TAX
EITHER DOES NOT EXIST AT ALL
BECAUSE OF THEIR- MISSION.
GRAPHICS INTENSIVE THOSE
DISTRICTS AS- WE SINCE THEY
WERE AS ARRAY THE FORTY TWO
YEARS AGO AS A SENATOR NIELSEN
IDENTIFIED IN SO EVEN AS THE
PROPERTY TAXES EVAN FLOW WITH
GROWTH AND CHANGING AND OF THE
SAYS VALUATION SOMEONE PICKS
FIVE. NO WORD FROM PROPERTY TAX
THE EVIDENCE BY EVEN JUST THE
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT DOWN HERE
EL DORADO. FIRE CHIEF ANNOUNCED
HE WOULD RESIGN IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE LINE FIREFIGHTER ON
THE JOB BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED SO WE
THINK THIS IS A GREAT FILM TO
THOSE THIS REVIEW OF IT. WITH
THE LACK OF OPPORTUNITY TO
RAISE RESOURCE ON THEIR OWN
OUTSIDE OF PROPERTY TAX THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SENATOR
STERN I WOULD I WOULD MOVE THE
MEASURE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
ALL RIGHT. NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT OF MEASURES
BEEN MOVED MISTER SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AND PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ALL I'M SORRY
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN
WOULD LIKE CLOSE. DAVID SURE I
JUST WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER- THE FOR HIS
COMMENTS HERE BUT ALSO IS
LEADERSHIP ENGAGEMENT AND
PULLING THIS. DEAL TOGETHER I'M
PROUD TO PUT MY NAME ON IT. OF
THIS HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADD
TO THE VEIL HOUSING STOCK IT'LL
LOCAL THROUGH GREATER. FAIRNESS
HI TECH THIS IS WAS. I TO MY
ENGAGE OF ON THIS AND THE
ELEVEN WILL BETTER PROTECT LIVE
AND PROPERTY FROM WILDFIRES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROUD TO HAVE A SET OF
BIPARTISAN. COOPER'S I. AT THIS
TO BOTH HOUSES AND TO THE
VOTERS ULTIMATELY THE VOTERS
WILL DECIDE IF THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE CONSTITUTIONAL
CHANGE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALL
RIGHT MISS SECTOR IF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL. CAN IS THE ADOPTED
AND PASSED TO SENATE. SHINS
NUMBER HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE STERN HI
STERN VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE
MEASURE PASSES- ALSO- WE LEFT
THE ROLE OPEN ON A CA OF FOUR
SO IF THE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THE ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG I OUR OIL IS FORTY
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS HERE
TODAY THANK YOU SENATORS AND
WITNESSES AND- PRESENTERS. WE
STAND ADJOURNED